yeah welcome to the server you're
playing badminton from Finland so I've
come up and play the part of so leading
to interesting open positions yeah g6 an
interesting line I am always liked the
idea of this line to get to get this
active Bishop placement I'm not quite
sure that I'm playing it within the best
possible way for white I mean the best
possible way yeah my default probably
two to cover to cover this
hmm yeah he said that he's on d5 with
many many pieces question is some how to
continue and yeah of course I was
thinking about something like rookie one
using doing something of the e-file and
this must be correct anyway what else
yeah I thought like taking and then
Bishop g5 how do you protect e7 now
maybe you can just castle now but this
time this can get can get very tricky so
Queen Queen a3 may be taking seven
queeny's if else looks quite good maybe
you can cast on her now there were
autologous maybe I should have thought
that longer yeah well kept Cassano yep
just return the pawn and hope that he's
got enough activity so might very well
be the case look coo coo queen hmm
there's also a sub money which i could
could also take it's not completely
ridiculous
now he's got quite active quite active
her pieces now you with the Queen
especially but how does it protect the
Queen side I can I can try the smooth
and then take koinnage holy Queen edge
for with nijah for coming yeah okay well
at least the zone Lucas is protected
just this one night each night g4s
really a brilliant nuisance and still be
seven SS hanging the queen is protecting
the rook so he doesn't have any dramatic
discoveries like Nigeria or something
yeah I can do that yeah probably just
take it and then grab b7
okay it still looks like like a rather
actor so it wouldn't surprise me if he
has got enough activity two to get this
to win some equal position yeah look at
you one maybe this one protecting d1 and
I am their seventh on and okay it's not
just the power that's Queen f7 nessa
quite something to to look yet okay not
sure what this is exactly doing it's not
attacking here I mean I can really just
intend Roxy soon maybe
stem I what I'm wondering about 25 look
be a truck da dropsy eight
swinging this could be all right sits at
least good for white ok let's keep it
simple
try to exchange of it
hmm it's probably i'm just a pawn Jeff
you fool no it's no no tricks here
unfortunately
check well it's not difficult or to even
to even keep this
yeah nothing you can do he's got UK one
anyway a queen a one this is still a bit
better for white because my king is a
bit bit quicker I can maybe maybe even
get the apron
add the Sun this is smoking oh I get the
pawn want to make sure that he doesn't
innovate here yae 43 and so on 20
seconds is a problem though don't even
get the pawn yeah yeah yeahs g5 was
really bad could have taken before
night Sam it's the wrong wrong colored
bishop of course it doesn't take he
wants to win on time now okay cannot be
no time ridiculous I why I actually lost
some time here oh really I wasn't really
paying attention anymore because I
thought I get to pawn anyway yeah well
okay enjoy a win I didn't didn't really
look anymore i forgot that i need to
really take the form okay what can you
do maybe yeah but I don't think I can I
should really prevent it maybe maybe
here I have some more precise moves g5
of course Russia's just giving this away
but I'm losing losing time here with 15
seconds I can just take now on g5 and
take a three and it's over just just
completely dead run too much time before
I so often um command interesting this
this around here if there was some some
some direct technical win Roxy seven
hour but the no okay Jamie Quincy for
Miriam but this is still I'm still a big
package in form a force even better
young yeah a4 is much better much better
fixing the pole on the oven a five and I
will win this for sure see a form now I
overlooked a form
yeah now Bishop p 2 a 4 and just King
before I've had the computers just
clanking b5 and ignores all this I
didn't want him to enter only two but
it's probably useless today yeah okay
this is of course just a draw because he
can always take g5 it's the wrong wrong
Bishop saw this rather late but then I
could have should affirm just gone for
the porn earlier and then secure the
draw I was I wasn't thinking clearly
because um it's clear that i cannot win
it so i should just go to our seven and
enter and end the game with with the
strong you know quite funny to to loosen
this fashion exactly here losing on time
where you can take f7 ok thanks for
watching